هدوء حده وتغيير لعنوان المرحله هكذا تبدو
الصوره الجديده بين مجموعه السبع والصين
سياسات مجموعه السبعه التي التامت في
هيروشيما انتقلت الى مفهوم جديد الا وهو
الحد من مخاطر العلاقه وليس قطعها الحد من
المخاطر هي كلمه السر الجديده على ما يبدو
في العلاقات المتوتره بين الغرب والصين
توتر مع التنين الاسيوي عبر عنه رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني
تشكل الصين اكبر تحدي في عصرنا للامن
والازدهار العالميين فهم يبدون قدرا
متزايدا من الاستبداد في الداخل والحزم في
الخارج بعيدا عزز كلام سوناك وبشكل مباشر
قالها لا سعي لقطع العلاقه مع الصين بل
يتوجب تقليل المخاطر
لا نسعى لقطع العلاقه مع الصين بل يجب
تقليل المخاطر الناتجه عن هذه العلاقه
تقليل المخاطر او التخلص منها يعني
بالنسبه لواشنطن بشكل اساسي وجود سلاسل
امداد مرنه وفعاله مع ضمان عدم التعرض
للاكراه او الضغوط من قبل الصين بحسب مقال
في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسولا فوندر لاين كانت اطلقت
في مارس الماضي الحركه بعدم السير في مسار
الانفصال مع الصين ويبدو انه من مصلحه
الطرفين ابقاء العلاقه فلا احد من
الجانبين مستعد لطلاق النهائي بلال
الوجداني العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات